Let's say the user presses the Home
button on the remote control
while playing back media.
On the left, we see something called
a Now Playing card and is useful for
keeping media playing in the background
while the user navigates elsewhere
on their TV.
Notice that the Now Playing
card appears front and
center right here in
the recommendations row.
And if the user would like to
jump back into their content,
they can simply select it.
For the Now Playing card to work,
you must use a MediaSession
to play your media.
We've already seen how the MediaSession
worked earlier in the Android Auto
section of the class.
Here I am inside the Playback Activity
section of our sample.
The Now Playing card will appear
automatically as soon as you set
the MediaSession to active.
So this is a feature you get nearly for
free.
There's just one thing you have to do,
and
that's to keep the Metadata of the
currently playing media item current.
You can see how this is done
inside the updateMetadata method.
Once this is done, the contents
of the Now Playing card will be
updated automatically
using this information.
So remember to call this method
whenever a new media item is played.
And here's a quick tip.
Remember to release the MediaSession
object when playback stops.
And that's it.
You can see a couple of more
details in the instructor notes.